when you think about the infrastructure
itself um when i first started here of
alzante and bitcoin beach it seemed like
uh it was a little bit more onerous um
the user experiences the infrastructure
wasn't quite there now my take from what
i hear from a number of different people
who have been is this much more kind of
lightning network enabled there's uh
micro payments there's cheap uh kind of
fast transactions what are people using
for the most part is it the cash apps of
the world is it strike is it some other
piece of infrastructure and like what
does that user experience look like for
them
we've actually uh worked hand-in-hand
with uh with a small uh upstart
lightning company called galloway money
and we've developed the bitcoin beach
wallet and we've been able to kind of
integrate a lot of things that are
innovative like there's a map function
in there so you can actually click on
this map and see all the places that are
accepting bitcoin throughout el salvador
and then actually pay them from a
lightning payment directly through the
map they don't have to create an invoice
or anything like that we also use user
names and similar to how strike is doing
with the user names and so i think
between strike and the bitcoin beach
wallet you know those are the ones that
are primarily being used mostly because
they get rid of the friction i mean it's
just makes it very fast to do a
lightning transaction actually faster
than cash and so that was something we
had to come overcome initially some of
the store owners would say ah it takes
longer i have to create an invoice i
have to wait where this it's actually
faster and so i think that's very
important as far as getting uptake on a
real retail level
absolutely
obviously everyone is talking about el
salvador now uh and i think most people
know the origin um of bitcoin beach and
the work that you and your team has done
there in el zante but uh the president
of el salvador uh obviously pushed
through the legislation uh and they now
have started to acquire bitcoin what are
people on the ground thinking about this
is this a positive development is there
concerns is there kind of a
whole spectrum of reactions or emotions
like what are you hearing on the ground
no there's definitely a whole spectrum
one people have to realize it's become
very political because the president is
pushing it the opposition parties are
suddenly very anti-bitcoin uh i think if
he would have
tried to outlaw bitcoin they would be
protesting in favor of bitcoin so you
know you have to kind of throw out that
just the normal politics that happen in
any country but on a real concern level
there are people here who just they
don't understand it they don't
understand what's happening they're
being told that they're going to be
forced to use bitcoin that it could drop
you know the value could go down in half
overnight and even today we've seen the
value drop down and that's very
concerning for people when they feel
like they're going to be forced to use
it but that's not the case the the way
the law is written nobody has to use
bitcoin it's something that i think the
way they're trying to do it is for over
time people to
slowly increase their exposure as they
kind of
understand the volatility of it and so
yeah i think it's just kind of natural
for people to have those um those
concerns when something new is being
pushed in yeah it makes complete sense
that i try to remind folks that uh
politics penetrate all kinds of things
like this here in the united states el
salvador and pretty much anywhere in the
world talk to me about the uh chivo
wallet and the atm uh plan that the
president has where they're kind of i
think they're putting 50 100 atms around
the country
what is the general perception that you
have right you've got a very unique seat
and then obviously you're a large
bitcoin proponent uh you've been very
active in helping on board a ton of
users in that country and also i think
um you know having the president kind of
do this you seem to be supportive of
that as well so how do you see the
rollout plan um in terms of maybe the
pros and cons in your opinion
i mean i think it'll be disastrous roll
out like any new technology roll out i
mean even the u.s government can't you
know roll out something with all the
resources they have behind them so you
know from from large governments to
large tech companies anytime something
new is rolled out it's very rocky at
first so i i'm assuming it'll be the
same here maybe i'll be pleasantly
surprised but
i assume for most people they won't be
able to use the wallet this week and
then generally over time they'll they'll
kind of catch up with the volume they'll
work out the bugs and so i wouldn't be
surprised if you know two weeks from now
people are calling this a failure
but
three months from now everybody
realizing wow this actually works and
it's revolutionizing the way commerce is
happening in el salvador it's saving
people money and it's giving people
access to the hardest money on earth
that people are able to save and
something that's not depreciating over
time so
i really have a long view of this it's
not a short game this is definitely a
long game and i think the president here
knows that and so
i think he will stick to it you know for
the long term even through the bumps and
yeah so i would just tell people to hold
their judgment till
we get at least six months out what's up
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today if
we're gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you ten dollars in
bitcoin for free it's that simple head
on over to sofi.com to get started today
thanks so much for watching and i hope
you come back and watch more of the best
business show tomorrow
[Music]